a group of students you know we went to
the the head of school and said you know
we're not going to be we refuse to be
taught by this misinformation anti-vaxx
anti-vaxxer guide even though it's a
compulsory module we demand to be moved
to another another module i mean
you could never believe this happen and
and the fact that
i don't get supported by you know the
the students are the ones who who you
know apparently are in the right to be
concerned about this you know the lack
of support the lack of support i mean
not just that but
the lack of support for you know what
you know the kind of nonsense i've had
to put up with throughout this has been
it's it's just it's remarkable how this
you just realize that there's nobody in
academy you've got a few
close colleagues who you trust right but
beyond that you you absolutely know that
you're not going to get any support
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i am very excited today to be
sitting with professor norman fenton of
queen mary university london he has a
phd in mathematics he is professor of
risk information management in the
department of electronic engineering and
computer science did i get that all
right norman that's right yeah well
welcome to dark horse
um i should say there's a lot more to
say about your credentials and
qualifications but if i were to try to
be exhaustive about it it would take up
all the time we have so i'm i'm not
going to do that
um but suffice it to say people can
check out your cv on your website we
will put a link to that website
and probably we should also say i don't
think it plays an important role but you
also uh
exist in a business context and so just
in the interest of full disclosure do
you want to say uh anything about yeah
so i'm director of the company
called agena which uh
specializes in um software for risk
management using probabilistic
bayesian methods
yes and i was going to say that you are
is it fair to say that you are a
bayesian in your approach
yes yes very much um
not by
uh you know not not starting from that
point but you know because i
uh
you know
i became a bayesian because we were
looking at trying to quantify
uncertainty for problems which there
wasn't a lot of data
and the only way to get any kind of
quantified
uh risk assessments was to combine data
with knowledge and that's where the kind
of like the bayesian approach came in
and so yeah and when we then started to
look at that as a method we use these
kind of like causal bayesian network
models
and you know that's a lot of our
research including a lot of the
data analysis that we've done on covid
has been using those causal bayesian
network models this episode of dark
horse is sponsored by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer
as we discuss in the sleep chapter of
hunter gatherer's guide intelligent life
that found its way to earth might be
surprised by a lot of what it found on
our planet but likely not by the fact of
sleep or dreams
sleep is necessary without good sleep we
are destined to be unhealthy and
unproductive yet more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep and
temperature is one of the main reasons
it is well known that individuals and
couples who sleep together often have
different optimal sleep temperatures
eight sleep allows fine-tuned
temperature regulation for both people
having a cool room and a warm bed is a
luxury that eight sleep makes easy to
obtain or a warm room with a cool bed
you make the choice without driving your
partner crazy
the pod pro cover by eight sleep is the
most advanced solution on the market for
thermal regulation
you can add the cover to any mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110
the temperature of the cover will adjust
each side of the bed based on your sleep
stages biometrics and bedroom
temperature reacting dynamically to
create the optimal sleeping environment
eight sleep users fall asleep 32 faster
reduce sleep interruptions 40 percent
and get more restful sleep overall
and with 30 percent more deep
restorative sleep on average they are
likely to benefit from faster physical
recovery improved hormone regulation and
increased mental clarity
finally the wake up feature which can
signal you with temperature change and
or slight chest level vibrations is much
gentler than any standard alarm
heather and i were both skeptical about
the value of a technologically enhanced
mattress and are now totally sold we are
surprised by how much we appreciate this
bed
go to eightsleep.com darkhorse and check
out the pod pro cover to save 150 bucks
at checkout eight sleep ships to the usa
canada and the uk that's eightsleep.com
darkhorse
our second sponsor for this episode is
american hartford gold
inflation is at its highest level in 40
years we all feel it at the grocery
store and the fuel pump interest rates
are soaring retirement accounts are in
real danger
if you want to better protect your
family's future you should consider that
people have been putting wealth into
precious metals for thousands of years
the more uncertain access to other
stores of value gets the more precious
precious metals are likely to become
call american hartford gold to see how
easy it is to get started
they can show you how to protect your
savings and retirement accounts by
diversifying your portfolio with
physical gold and silver composed of
actual atoms
all it takes to get started is a short
phone call and they'll have physical
gold and silver delivered right to your
door or inside your ira or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an a plus rating from the
better business bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients
call them now and they will give you a
percentage of your first qualifying
order back in free silver call american
hartford gold at 866-828-1117
that's 866-828-1117
or text darkhorse to 998899
again that's 866 866-828-1117
or text darkhorse to 998899
so that's a beautiful way of describing
it um i hope i caught it it was that you
were combining
data with knowledge yeah and that that
requires an approach and in particular
causal knowledge yeah
help explain sort of biases
um missing data
so it's all about
looking for explanations it's it's not
just a classical number crunching which
is what most statisticians do you know
we we're looking for causal explanations
why the data
is is what it is yeah so if i uh this is
going to be a little bit challenging
since most of uh the dark horse
followership is probably listening on
audio we're not going to do any visuals
here and they would be
important if we were going to do an
exhaustive explanation of
the bayesian approach but just to take
one reducto ad absurdum
if you had a
test
for
smallpox
that was
uh
99
accurate in the positive direction
and you gave it to a random person
in los angeles today and they came up
positive that would not say they had a
99 chance of having smallpox because
small parks as far as we know is not
anywhere in circulation the percentage
of the population that has it is zero
yeah so you would have to be very
skeptical of that positive even though
the test itself might be uh
um
chemically very effective at detecting
small pockets yeah in that case it could
be like 99.9 percent accurate i mean the
key thing is this is where people get if
that even with during the covert debate
with the forced positives on the pcr
testing it's a very relevant question
course bayes comes in here it's all
about
it's it's it's all very well having a
small probability of a false positive so
you might it might only be you know well
under one percent chance that if you
don't have the disease you don't have
the virus or smallpox in your example
that you're wrongly test positive so
it's you know it's
99 of the time when you when you don't
have it it gives you the right answer
right so it seems like it's really
accurate but of course
if if the incidence rate is let's say
1 000. of course a small box it's even
lower but just let's suppose we've
covered it's 1 000
right what that means is that in a
thousand if you take 10 000 people
right
only about 10 of them
will have the disease
but of the other 990 or whatever you're
going to get this 1
false positive rate so you're going to
get 19 about 99 of those who don't have
the disease testing positive so you've
got about 110 testing positive of whom
only about 10 generally have the disease
so the probability that you've got the
disease having tested positive
is actually less than 10 percent
right and that's what people get wrong
and people this has been such a problem
explaining this throughout some people
saying we know they say they we we know
that the the false positive rate for pcr
testing is is less than one percent it's
only point three percent you know you
know less than a third of a percent so
how can you turn around and say that a
lot of people are asymptomatic with test
positive haven't got the disease this
rubbish but of course no we know that we
know from empirical data we've actually
got beta
on asymptomatics and whether or not they
but they're testing with false positives
or not and like over 80 percent of them
who tested positive did not have a virus
they really were false positives wow
well i i must tell you one of the things
that heather and i scratch our heads
about all the time is that we are what
two and a half years into this pandemic
and the testing is still
so crude and our understanding of what
it implies is
so poor
how can that possibly be
well i think that the the testing was
always part of the creating the
narrative i mean look i i
how did i first get into trouble as it
were how was i first labelled a spreader
of misinformation during this whole
thing it was actually when
the mass testing started in the uk in
the late summer of 2020
and that was mass testing of
asymptomatic people for whom we knew
that you know a high proportion weren't
going to be having the virus but they
were reports they started to report they
were as always just reported case
numbers so you look at the government
dashboard and you see this increasing
number of case numbers right and a case
is just a positive someone testing
positive on a pcr test right so i'm
looking and saying how am i saying this
is going right up but actually it's the
amount of testing that's going up so
let's just divide let's perform the
radical act of simple division we'll
divide the number of cases by the number
of tests and when you do that you see
actually there wasn't much of anything
flat yeah that radical act of simple
division is what cast me as a spreader
of misinformation from that point on
that was that was the you know that was
the end of my sort of academic
credibility as far as you know as far as
the
the uh accepted academia is concerned
well this is what this is one of the
things that's so upsetting to me is that
yes that radical act of division doing
it per capita and discovering that your
trend was an artifact
an obvious artifact of the fact that you
were doing more tests and i mean let's
let's take my reductive ad absurdum yeah
if we were to play that same game with
smallpox today and we were to start
testing people for smallpox with a
highly accurate test with a very low
false positive rate right and we were to
let's say we set out to test the entire
population well you and i both know what
that would look like we would see the
number of cases of small people
the more you test the more it goes up
right and the fact is the actual number
of cases would be zero throughout but
the number of apparent cases would be
would be accelerating and we know what
the news
narrative would be
yeah absolutely the problem is
that as much as it is difficult to
understand bayesian priors and all the
things that go into a proper analysis
the error that you are describing is one
any
high school student of probability ought
to understand perfectly well so the idea
that our public health apparatus got it
wrong
um
stretches
the bounds of credulity how could they
have missed that per capita analysis was
necessary we've done it long before this
whole covered thing we also did we were
also involved in some of the you know
studies which looked to the why you know
people get this kind of reasoning wrong
and it's not just us than various
studies in here but i mean i can give
you so there's lots of studies which
show that you know very highly
intelligent people even
people with with you know
quantitative knowledge people who have
kind of like scientific degrees don't
get these don't don't get the simple
point okay
and you know i i've also been involved
in a lot of legal work and this whole
thing amounts to what's called the
prosecutor's status law where they they
mix the probability of the evidence the
probability of the evidence given the
hypothesis they confuse the probability
of the hypothesis given the evidence so
it's it's basically the same thing as
what we've been discussing here which is
the assumption that that one over 100
that the 99
accuracy is the 99
chance that you you don't have the
disease so anyway the point is they get
it wrong and i've i spoken you know i
spoken with the top the most brilliant
judges for example in this
and tried to give and we give you know
what i think is a very simple like
visual explanation just doing it with
sort of you know stick men you show that
the sort of argument i gave before but
actually showing it so you can really
see
and they say and it'll say things like
it doesn't matter how many times you you
say i still i still think it's wrong i
still think that
right yeah i think you're wrong in your
conclusion
the rational base answer is wrong
according to them
right it's really a question you know i
don't know that the right bayesian
environment exists
developmentally for us to develop the
correct intuitions but i think many of
us have looked at the monty hall problem
for example yeah and thought
i get it but wow does that feel wrong
every time i go through it you know it
just it just feels off
um let's let's talk for a second about
the the
prosecutor's fallacy which uh it's been
many many years since i've thought about
it but i think i remember it and again i
think a reductio ad absurdum is probably
useful right if you have
somebody
uh arrested running from the scene of a
crime uh
with the murder weapon
in hand and you test their dna
and their dna matches to a one in a
million level of probability uh dna
found at the scene that is indeed very
strong evidence that they committed the
crime on the other hand absent that
evidence if you went out into the
population and tested everybody's dna
and found somebody who was a very good
match that's incredibly weak evidence
because there will be people in the
population that
match at all of these uh loci
just by happenstance and they didn't
commit the crime there will be multiple
of them so you can't say that it's
evidence against one
um
and so you know the prosecutor might
come in and say look this is dna
evidence the chances that it's wrong is
uh you know less than one in a million
right
on the other hand it's very much like
the smallpox uh exactly the same and and
what's more they do all the time even
though interesting enough there was in
the uk the
um i don't know it's like in america but
in the uk judges
are told to be on the lookout for it and
they're supposed to stop any any um
lawyer or expert witness
make an assertion which amounts to the
prosecution's facts it's supposed to be
struck off the problem is they don't
know it when it's done and i've been
i can't tell how many
you know times i've seen it done or um
or at least yeah i mean it it it still
happens all the time so the prosecutor
you know that's why it's called the
prostitutes fantasy will say well you
know the chances of um
the chance that this this man is
innocent given this evidence is one in a
million no the chance of getting his
evidence if he's innocent is one million
but you know if there's if there's 10
million possible suspects then he's
actually only only one of ten who could
have been you know had that same match
in dna right okay well then this this
raises what i think is the most
uncomfortable question in all of kovid
for me i think maybe not quite but
when i look at what took place
over the course of the last two and a
half years
i am left with the following conundrum
it appears at first blush to be
a case of massive incompetence
with respect to our response but when i
look in detail i see that not only did
we get everything wrong but we got
everything backwards
if you did exactly the opposite of what
you were told in each and every case
you would have actually been doing
almost almost exactly what you should do
right
you know they shut down the beaches
where should you have been oh beach
would have been a great place to be if
you'd stayed at the beach for the whole
pandemic you'd have been safe right yeah
um so you know
go home
and don't come back to get medical
treatment until you're already very sick
no you should treat from the first hint
that you have been in contact with covet
let alone come down with it and going
home is exactly what's going to infect
the people who are trapped with you
there right so we can go down the list
you know
should you take should you count on a
repurposed drug
no stay away from those things they're
very dangerous what you should do is
take this
immunosuppressive injection that we call
a vaccine
right
um
well
that's going to make matters worse right
the very nature of the vaccine is so
narrowly targeted that it actually
appears to have selected for a
proliferation of variance so if i go
down the list we can identify 10
12 places where we were told something
very definitive about what we should
individually do and what we should
collectively do and each one of them was
the inverse of the right answer now my
contention if it had been one decision
then incompetence could explain how you
would get the opposite of the right move
but if it's 10
12
different decisions and we got the
inverse of the right answer in every
case the probability that that happens
through incompetence
is vanishingly small
yep
yeah i agree and i always think that
there was a there was
you know there was a motive behind i
mean you know
we called conspiracy theorists for
mention the word you know mention the
words the great reset but that was said
right from the beginning this is the
opportunity for great research do you
know the first time i heard that
expression i wasn't really well tuned
into this this one these these things a
lot of people were tuned into it well
before me and i wasn't right
the first time i was i i got really
frightened about this and realized this
is not what this is you know it's not a
coincidence it's not just a freak that
they're getting all these things wrong
was when i actually was invited onto a
panel
um of
people who were involved supposedly with
the early covered research because we'd
already right from the beginning we
published a paper where we found out
we'd already picked up on the fact that
the
uh the infection fatality rates were
exaggerated
right and so we did the bayesian
analysis we were one i think one first
to publish a paper peer review paper on
that and so i at that point that was not
considered to be too disrespectful it
wasn't considerably too out of sync with
the narrative
um so i got involved i was at that point
invited on to quite a few things sort of
local things in the uk i was on this um
this panel um with experts
and
every one of the experts on that pound
there was three others me and three
others and they all mentioned this great
reset they said they said this is they
all said it's fantastic because this was
actually when the lockdown was really
hard after two months it was in it was
early june 2020 in the uk we've been
locked down solid for two over two
months at that point and they were
saying it's fantastic you know because
this is great for the environment this
is this is exactly what we need to they
specifically said for for climate change
and this is and they were saying things
this is the opportunity to completely
reset sight and they said yep they said
klaus forms words this is the
opportunity of the great reset all the
other speakers said it i was shocked i
was completely
you know that's when i realized this is
you know i said right i said from the
beginning of fairly soon after that
which i got a lot of flack for that
these covered lockdowns seem to me to be
a precursor for the climate lockdowns
and you know that's i think that is it
all fits into that everything that was
done and is being done in the name of
kovid fits into that kind of like a
gender 2030
narrative
well i must say you know i'm open to
that possibility i'm not quite ready i
see a number of things that could
explain it
um you know
some of them
yeah
there's a conspiracy hypothesis here to
be certain but a mundane one right you
could get to an absolutely upside down
prescription
for
personal and public health
if
you decided for whatever reason that you
wanted to deliver the maximum number of
injections
uh you know and that could be for simple
reasons of economic profit right if you
decided that delivering injections was
the objective of the exercise then
everything else follows actually
now i'm not saying that that is what
happened but i'm saying that as between
that hypothesis
and a
great reset that is driving these things
it's hard for me to sort between them
because they both predict the same thing
well i'll tell you why i i think that
the um i don't think it was the um
the vaccine narrative driving it there
and i'll tell you why because
my view was that it actually wasn't a
conspiracy in the sense of you know a
small number of you know
um powerful men sort of deciding this
was the way we were going to go but the
fact that all the all all the key
influences right we're brought in we're
already bought into that idea that we
need to do something drastic we need
drastic changes to society right to
tackle this whole you know climate
change uh you know they call it a
catastrophe or emergency or whatever
right they're so bought into that
and that was indeed you know these other
people on the panel and many other
academics and people like if you think
about all the people who are advising
the governments right i mean take people
in northfield in the uk neil ferguson
susan mickey who made major
contributions on you know neil ferguson
you know obviously where that he was the
one with the the ridiculous prescription
predictions on the number of deaths and
susan mickey is the the communist who uh
was advising the government on the on
how to control you know this behavioral
control
all that type of things you know she's
now been appointed as head of the world
health organization um
science team but anyway that's another
thing but all those people and
throughout government as well and i'm
sure it was the same us a bit different
at that time but certainly the uk was
people were taking their uh we're seeing
what was happening in the uk and doing
the same very much and everywhere you
looked with these same the same clique
of the you know elitist kind of
academics
very very with this with this world view
that you need much greater control
over what people are doing in order to
confront confront this you know
potentially catastroph well as i would
call it this catastrophic uh climate
change problem and so i think that was
that was driving it and the vax and then
you know the vaccines became after that
yeah okay that even more convenient we
can keep people you know locked down you
know for them it meant they could keep
people locked down even further and
longer until the vaccines came around so
those people certainly weren't
into they had no interest in vaccines
from the sort of profit angle it was
simply it's it absolutely fitted their
their agenda for sort of continual
control and lockdown
well you know
so there are a number of topics we
should hit on here i should tell you i
do have real climate concerns i feel
certain that we are being misled with
respect you know the models are obvious
nonsense
but i do believe that there is a
potentially lethal problem to humanity
lurking in the form of frozen methane in
the arctic
and the problem is what we have is a
very polluted academic environment so we
can't really sort out how big a threat
it is and how close we are yeah to a
threshold so um you know i i want to be
careful that we don't assume there is no
problem just because corrupt people are
using uh the threat to manipulate us
which they clearly are
um
so i don't know i don't know what you
think about that and i don't know
frankly how how deeply you've delved
into the question of climate change
well the funny thing is um
i was uh
on i was actually i co-presented
a bbc documentary called climate change
by numbers in 2015 with hannah fry and
so david uh professor david
spiegelhalter and that's an interesting
experience in itself now because of
i they chose there were supposed to be
three mathematicians to look at the sort
of the numerical issues surrounding
right climate change and i was supposed
to be the one looking at the sort of
probabilistic
statements and models right and
uh and they chose us because we didn't
have we'd never done we'd never
supposedly never had any thoughts before
never commented on climate change i was
supposed to be independent but because
it was the bbc it wasn't at all
independent i mean i i came in fairly
open-minded and i left that program as a
complete skeptic because i saw the total
corruption sign it was the i mean i
can't i can't say it i can't speak about
everything because i'm actually i
actually you know had to i didn't sign
some
uh you know i was under some sort of
agreement where i can't
speak completely freely about what went
on there and there's some things which i
think are quite you know quite shocking
but it was it was total it was total
bias it was a lot of stuff was you know
it was ridiculous okay but but this
actually strikes me as a perfect case
for a bayesian right you and i can both
look at the academic environment and say
well i know what's going to happen here
because you've gotten you've got
a group of people who are convinced that
we have an emergency and therefore
anything you publish that suggests the
emergency might not be as serious as we
think it might not be progressing as
rapidly as we think those people are
going to be shunned they'll be destroyed
that's going to leave you a intense
structural confirmation bias inside of
climate science right but what that
leaves you with
is no information about the reality it
does not leave you with evidence that
there's no problem
all right and so i get that yeah
so my idea
my approach has been
um
they keep telling me that you know we're
going to have an ice-free arctic
so far we don't have an ice-free arctic
that tells me that they are ahead of the
curve right i was told that kilimanjaro
was going to be free of glaciers they're
retreating but it's not free of glaciers
likewise glacier national park still has
glaciers so
all of these things tell me that i am
being misled about the speed but then on
the other side
the fact
i don't know of a challenge to the idea
that there is a tremendous quantity of
frozen methane in the arctic
and
the question is
at the point that we unleash
the
chemistry the atmospheric chemistry that
makes methane an intense uh warming
agent is straightforward doesn't depend
on a model
right and so the question is do we reach
a threshold where we release enough
methane you release methane it causes a
slight warming that backs the
ice cap back a bit that releases more
methane so you get a positive feedback
and that question about whether or not
we reach a place with the frozen methane
in the arctic that the glacial retreat
that we can see that doesn't depend on
anybody's model predicts that we will
reach a point at which suddenly this
will no longer be even
uh controllable in principle by human
beings i worry about that and i worry
that the biggest threat to us is the
corrupt academic environment that makes
it impossible to address that question
objectively
yeah no i i get what you're saying and
the problem is i i fundamentally don't
understand
the notion that the humor that then of
course i'm not disputing that there
there may well be uh serious that you
know climate change isn't a real thing
but the notion that humans that we as
humans you know by you know dry years by
you know driving electric cars instead
of petrol cars are going to stop that is
is insane
it's just it's just insane to me yeah it
is and you know i must tell you i don't
think you know when i hear the solutions
that are being offered by those who
claim to be in the know i'm
unimpressed that they know nearly i mean
it's it's rather like the cobit response
i just don't believe these people
understand the problem well enough to
address it that said
you know if it were me
i would have my foot on the gas with
respect to fusion power because with
fusion power we do begin to get a you
can take an electric world you can plug
it into fusion so if we build an
electric world
ahead of time right it doesn't save the
world but if you then discover viable
fusion technology you can plug your
electric world into the fusion
technology that does make a huge dent
and also with fusion you can pull carbon
out of the atmosphere if that's what you
need to do right nothing else is going
to provide enough power for us to do
that so
from my perspective you know
it's it's like we repurpose drugs and
covet right the right solution is just
not on anybody's tongue right or you
know those few who are are heretics and
so that tells me the whole system is
uh corrupt and putting us in danger by
at the very least running out the clock
yeah yeah yeah
but let's um let's move back towards uh
kovid and uh the reason that i was
inspired to invite you on dark horse all
of a sudden which was a piece that you
i've now forgotten were you was it sub
stack
i just do it on my i've got a wix blob
that's i mean my my web page is which i
just put yeah
i've also got it on yeah a couple of
i've got a couple of blog blogger and
i've got a blogger account yeah okay
well that's old school yeah i know and i
just got around to doing substance yeah
the trouble isn't it yeah
it's just that i i feel that if you
substitute then people start thinking is
this in this for the money
that sense of that so just want to keep
you know sure although you could do your
substance for free if you wanted
to even just when you go on it don't you
you still got to you've got a message
which sort of suggests that you might
you know need to subscribe and i don't
know yeah
i mean i i get it and i and i very much
appreciate that you want to uh
broadcast the message that you're not
doing this for the money you're
describing things as they are but in any
case the content of your piece
was about a uh a topic that has become
unfortunately near and dear to my heart
which is the corruption of wikipedia
um as you know and as you mentioned in
your article
heather and i have been
libeled by wikipedia pages that
ostensibly describe our role in the
world from
relatively early
in the pandemic at least
you know early in the
public health campaigns against
repurposed drugs and for
these transfection agents which we are
calling vaccines for some reason
but in any case
i have not known
the effect of having one's wikipedia
page accuse
you of spreading misinformation
is huge and i would also point out quite
unmeasurable
right and just to to lay this out from
my personal perspective before we get to
uh what's happened to you and what you
discovered about what's going on at
wikipedia
youtube demonetized dark horse
uh the sword that people see sticking
through the counter behind me signifies
the sort of damocles hanging over the
podcast
and
basically that in the space of one hour
they demonetized both our channels and
knocked out more than half of our family
income
i believe they probably were going to
shut down the channel and i think i
probably got in the way of that by
talking about this on joe rogan's
program which alerted people to the
hazard of censorship at uh at youtube
um but in any case
this demonetization by youtube of course
puts us in the predicament of having to
keep a roof over our children's heads
and and all of those things
um in other ways
now what are those other ways for people
you know we were
professors that was a very secure we
thought
form of income at the point that
madness drove us from our professions we
generated accidentally this
alternative way of feeding our family it
worked well then youtube with the you
know a couple of
a couple of moves got in the way
um
the next
way to fund is to go through our viewers
who
youtube has
uh behind the scenes influence over who
gets to see the channel how many of them
there are etc who gets unsubscribed
without taking any action
but most importantly we can seek
advertisers to sponsor the podcast but
for an advertiser trying to decide what
to do to
uh to gain
uh some exposure for their product
they're of course going to go to our
wikipedia pages and to have our
wikipedia pages accuse us of being
dangerous spreaders of
misinformation
therefore obviously endangering human
lives that's not something advertisers
want to mess with so the question of
given
a
private unaccountable non-transparent
system at youtube combined with a out of
control
mechanism at wikipedia the ability to
disrupt somebody's capacity to earn
is staggering
yeah right and that's before we get to
just the simple fact of the reputational
damage and what effect that has on
interacting with people in the world
so all right um what did you find what
happened to you and what did you find
about what's going on at wikipedia yeah
so what happened to me was that um
i
was
uh i was about to give evidence in a
fun life in one of the think it's it's
claimed to be the first
um case of
uh
of an
the first case brought against a
government a national government
on covet mandates which has actually got
to court it's in jakarta in indonesia
and i was an expert brought in as an
expert witness on the data
supporting
the vaccine efficacy and safety right so
i was um
uh
scheduled to give this evidence and
about
a week before
i was going to give the evidence the
lawyers on outside said
do you realize that
the um
wikipedia is saying this has got you
down as under covert 19 misinformation
and it had a statement there which i
don't know if i should maybe um
i could can read out what it was it's
it's basically says um
in march 2021
so it says under the heading covid19
this information in march 2021
fenton was one of several academics who
put their name to a document seeking to
persuade the british government not to
pass covet 19 legislation blah blah blah
and this then quotes people saying it
was ridiculous um the vaccines in
question hadn't established safety
profile
we showed a blatant disregard for the
facts irresponsible in the extreme now
whether or not
let's put aside what whether um
the claims that they said we made were
true or not i never signed that was
simply that whole thing was was false it
was it was it was based on a highly
misleading
times article
that had been published in in march um
2021
um by a guy by theirs there's the
science editor called uh tom whipple
and
it was easy i say this this this idea
that i'd signed this document claiming
that the the that it said but it
actually said that the vaccines they
claimed that the um the vaccines were
causing the uh the second that the
vaccines were causing the second wave of
deaths which was happening at the time
and i'd signed a document basically
presented it you know convincing the uh
government legislation no such thing
happened i never signed there was no
such thing happen what it was based on
was this misleading report as follows
right i happen to be one of quite a
large number of people who are on this
heart group which is basically a group
i can't remember where it stands but
it's a group which has right from the
beginning
attempted to put
uh let's say
a more rational narrative on that you
know look at the you know look at the
covert data more rational viewpoint than
what we're being presented by the
governments you know people would call
us a group of skeptics i'd say but it's
you know very you know we've got you
know there's a broad you know quite a
cross-section of people there you know
we've got very very senior clinicians
pathologists you know uh data scientists
etc psychologists that you know a whole
group of people and what happened was
that actually i didn't even really i
didn't even know about this because it's
not like we somehow sit around
discussing everything you know that
we're gonna do
um and i'm not one of the leaders i'm
not one of this sort of the uh the
organizer anything like that but
basically put they put out just a
compendium of papers a compendium of
nine i think it was 13 or whatever
um over a dozen papers
which covered various things right one
of which one of which was a paper by um
a statistician called joel smalley where
he simply raised he'd simply shown
that there appeared to be a spike in
the deaths
it's a spike in all cause mortality
after the vaccine program was rolled out
and he simply raised the issue saying
well look this needs to be this same
which you need to you need to look at so
there was one paper
not off belly i was not the author of
any paper in that report so my name this
idea that i signed a document
you know this is is is is simply an
incredible lie
um
my name was simply listed on the inside
cover
as one of the men one of the many dozens
of members of heart
right and then translated that into
that to me signing a document which was
which which was saying that the vaccines
were causing the second wave
of injuries so that was the that's the
basis of what the the
and and this you know the statement that
was in wikipedia
about me which i i mean i was i didn't i
hadn't looked at my wikipedia entry for
for years for years it's not right i
didn't didn't it's not something i
thought about but then to be told just
before you're going to give evidence you
know as an expert witness and a chaos
that wikipedia is saying that you're a
spread of misinformation
right and you're claiming wrongly
against all all the evidence that you
know that the vaccines are causing these
sort of mass deaths which you know was
never saying anyway
um and even the article was never saying
that that was the thing the article
never said it at all
um
it was just ridiculous now as it so
happens
from the
the lawyers in the case kind of like
managed
to turn this i did i mean i didn't do
anything about it i thought
i don't edit
right what can you
i can't get i'm looking i'm not going to
get people to try and go in edit i
didn't link and the lawyers were sort of
quite comfortable with it because they
wanted to actually show
at the beginning of my evidence that
this was an example
of what happens to people who actually
do present a counter narrative but they
get these liars about them uh spread on
on on wikipedia
so hold on i i have to interrupt you
here and just make one point um
people who have viewed a lot of
dark horse
will remember that heather and i on one
of our live streams
covered a paper
by christine
benn
in which it did show
that there is a
an increase in all cause mortality for
people who got the mrna-based vaccines
the reverse is true there is a slight
benefit to the dna based adenovectored
vaccines
but i just want to point out that
not only were you
libeled and
a simple lie told about you you having
signed a document that you did not sign
but the content wasn't misinformation
exactly i mean that's a separate exactly
that's
you know a lot of the things that that
were actually said there of course yeah
we've also done work on all calls
looking at all calls mortality after um
the vaccination and
what we can certainly conclude is that
there are certainly no there is
certainly no reduction in all calls
mortality and the vaccinated compared
with the unvaccinated so well i would
also say
i would also point out as long as we're
here
that
this is a measure
in which the mortality
is
likely to go up with time in other words
absolutely vaccines have only existed
for a year and a half and so what we're
looking at is that so far we've seen an
increase in deaths but to the extent
that people might die five years ten
years after these vaccinations as a
result of
some interference with their normal
physiology then those numbers would
climb so
we can simply say that there is already
evidence of an increase in all-cause
mortality which ought to be an alarming
fact to anybody interested in whether or
not this
mass vaccination campaign was
ill-advised from the get-go which it
clearly was um
but uh the numbers we're looking at are
conservative because it's still early
yeah yeah and then there is absolutely a
concern about the
safety and if so i would actually you
know
although i never signed that document at
the time we didn't know any we didn't
really know anything at the time and and
that article
was was simply it was actually the
imagination of the editor of the times
into what he was interpreting what was
said and interestingly enough in his
article this is the other thing he never
ever linked to the actual heart document
so people couldn't even see what was
said they were only getting his
interpret his his interpret his
misinterpretation of what was said which
then
you know you then get these other people
on wikipedia then using what and they
they themselves put another
interpretation of what his
interpretation of what was said and you
get this you get this nonsense okay so
the interesting thing then is that so i
didn't do anything about it and and you
know
whether it the extent to which it
compromised me
in my expert evidence i i don't know it
may have it may well have done because
people still do look at you know they
still do look wikipedia but there was a
development after that right where i
realized just how
um bad i got a tip off
right about
a set of editing that started to go on
then off with with this
um
uh wikipedia because i think i might
have mentioned it i can't remember i
mentioned on twitter so obviously some
people did start to look at
people who do this sort of stuff did
start to look at what was going on right
and
what we found out was that
one editor
had tried to at least insert
the following statement that the fenton
denied under oath that that statement of
wikipedia was true
right so that was inserted
that got immediately removed by
so there's one guy
this this uh i mean it's not it's not
doctor because it's actually open it's
not like he's it's a guy called axe
brown who goes under the wiki editor
name of alex brown right who i found out
later was like
very very well known and he was involved
in the
in you know in the
uh the nonsense put on your um wikipedia
page he was one a key one there and he's
been he's been key in a lot of these
people you know uh malone uh mccullough
he's been involved you know in
he's uh yeah he's trashed he's tried to
trash a lot a lot of people he then
uh he remembered he he has this right
he's he's an admin
i mean none of these things that i know
anything about what it is but he's got
these admin rights where he can just you
know he he'll just delete it and if
people start putting it in again he'll
just block those people and that's
basically what was happening so he just
deleted that one where someone just put
in a factual statement which you can see
on video there's actually video evidence
of me of me
under oath in the call saying that i
denied i denied that those accusations
in that those accusations
were not true so he just stated a fact
and that that wasn't allowed to be this
was this was not alex brown this was
somebody else attempted somebody else's
simple factual statement that you have
said under oath that you didn't which
had that been in your wikipedia entry
would have caused anyone reading it to
understand ah
there's controversy over whether or not
this
did or did not take place and that you
yourself had said under oath that you
didn't obviously you would not want to
risk perjury if you had in fact signed
this letter so it strongly suggests
something might be wrong with that claim
so so um
that got that got deleted and then
there were a few what then happened was
that there was another guy someone else
actually tried to fix
fix it completely by trying to give the
background of what the heart document
actually
said so he'd gone in there and edited it
by giving the full history about this
this times article and how the times
article got changed over time and and
how it didn't represent what was said in
heart
and basically every every time that was
put up alex brown within seconds within
seconds this guy
even like it doesn't matter any time of
day you know or if it's if it's like
three in the morning at five in the
morning you know when it gets up you'll
have deleted it right so this was going
on so it was kind of like a war going on
and this went on apparently a few times
at which point alex brown simply blocked
that person just they just simply block
them so they're not allowed to do
they're not allowed to do anything
for trying to introduce a simply factual
corrective statement
into so and this was and and that's
that's the way that's the way they work
um now there is a there is a kind of an
interesting
outcome which where maybe i've done
better than you incidentally i mean i've
been looking at
um i mean some of the things i looked at
your
what there's this very interesting thing
which i'd like to maybe come on to
because with you
i notice it says
that um david gorski and of course um
uh i know you know
any any sort of skeptics anybody with
any any kind of um
who's done any sort of reasonable work
in sort of challenging narrative would
have come under the you know would have
been attacked by david gorsky right we
know that right we know this this this
guy right and i notice it says
in the david gorsky describe weinstein
as a prominent covenant 19 crontarion
and spread of disinformation and one of
the foremost purveyors of kovitz 19 you
know disinformation blah blah blah i
mean so
uh yeah so that that's that's the kind
of thing but um
he
um
so he i think works he must also work
with this this guy alex brown in fact do
you know that there's are you aware that
there's an article which claims that
which is you know on
um
uh which i found on you know just on
on the internet by a search which which
claims that gorsk himself is a kind of
like a master um wikipedia editor and
has been for a number of years going
under the name of um he's denied it but
very weakly under the name of um
i'm just going to get it up here
of
mars cell did you know that
i did not know that you should look you
should look that up because then you can
see it now
clearly he's clearly a very powerful
force in creating the fictional
counter narrative that is so
and he works with and he clearly must
work with people like this this alex
brown right i mean that's the other
thing what is alex brown on his own web
page
he um he's a retired computer programmer
who had his phd was in english yes what
the hell is this guy this guy is the
gatekeeper now of most medical
information on wikipedia
it's even worse than that because
we all understand
that there is something marvelous
about
a
an actually encyclopedic encyclopedia
right the ability
it is it is an incredibly powerful
uh enlightening force a democratizing
force to have a source that you can go
to it's not perfect it's never been
perfect but the idea that if i want to
know
you know
um you know whether uh brontosaurus
uh is likely to you know have you know
have been strictly vegetarian in nature
it's a very good chance i can go to
wikipedia and find out that answer in
short order right or if i want to know
something about uh
vaccine orbital vaccine intervals uh
atomic orbitals or uh you know anything
if i want to know something about what a
cumulonimbus cloud is
yeah so we all have been trained that
this
uh library of alexandria
to the 10th power
is at our fingertips
but
how powerful is it to have the library
of alexandria
have a mechanism whereby if you need a
per a particular person's reputation
destroyed we can arrange that right now
this all of course raises the question
who this alex brown is is he motivated
um is he just personally confused about
covet and he's a zealot is he motivated
by some conflict of interest that we
can't see
um and
you know then we get to
this
even more difficult problem i knew that
i was being
libeled by wikipedia
but what is there to do about it because
wikipedia
has
section 230 protection here in the
united states which means that because
it is a platform rather than a publisher
at least by the formal definition it is
not responsible for what is there so
somebody who wishes to libel you and has
the wherewithal to become a powerful
editor
of wikipedia has the ability to insert
into the equivalent of our library of
alexandria extremely destructive false
information about you which at the very
least will cause people who don't know
anything about you to throw up their
hands and not know what to think it's
going to cause people to stay away from
you because they just don't want to get
involved that's
that's incredibly powerful and nobody is
legally responsible for it
um
at wikipedia because of the
the vague relationship between
wikimedia the entity that
provides the service and the people who
actually write the entries so somehow
this has to be fixed
because there's nowhere to go but the
thing is as i think i mentioned in my
article um jimmy uh we'll see jimmy
wells was the
governor he knows he's been alerted to
this particular problem this particular
problem this one editor alex brown on
numerous occasions and he's recognized
it he's actually responded
to tweets about it
and he's done nothing so he's away he's
fully aware of the problem he knows it's
a genuine problem he knows that people
he must know that people are being
libeled and yet
he allows it to happen why he can do it
he can he can stop this guy just like
that he can
why doesn't he
well i guess i would work
from a different angle and i would say
in a world with any functional tools
whatsoever we would be in a very
different place with respect to
something like covet
the reason that we ended up where we are
is that the tools to
derail anyone who simply evaluated the
evidence and came to the logical
conclusion that there was something
wrong with the idea that we had
no
drugs available to treat it that there
was something wrong with the idea that
these transfection agents were vaccines
in the first place that they were
safe enough to contemplate a mass
vaccination campaign that they were
effective at controlling covet in any
meaningful way
the evidence is clear enough and so the
only way
to maintain the feeble narrative that we
have been incessantly sold
is to have a power tool for dealing with
skeptics
as they arise
right skeptic becoming a skeptic in this
case is as simple as reviewing the
evidence that makes you a skeptic if
you're an honest broker and you review
the evidence you will welcome to the the
club of the skeptics right so you have
to be able to deal with everybody who
enters there and what's more you have to
be able to punish them right and even if
you can't stop uh malone or a mccullough
or a weinstein or a fenton
you can use them as cautionary tales
right when somebody even if somebody
knows
that i'm no liar
and that i've been very good at
predicting things about
what took place during covid when they
see what has happened to my wikipedia
page and they imagine oh no
what would i do
right they don't want any part of it and
so
it's a massive deterrent yeah it is it
is an incredibly powerful weapon for
controlling
um
the effective belief of of civilization
and um the amount of power there would
be hard to overestimate
yeah yeah so you think that in fact
are you there for saying that that jimmy
wells is maybe
um is bought into the narrative himself
to such an extent that he thinks it's
actually a good thing that this is that
this is happening well i don't know and
and the problem is we don't know with
any of the people who are behaving
paradoxically whether they are doing so
because i mean look
you know psychology is complex
some people
may be
genuinely frightened
by what happens if they follow the
evidence where it leads and they may
then
uh due to the cognitive dissonance
rationalize to themselves
that the um
the mainstream narrative is more or less
in the ballpark
that the skeptics are
uh
out over their skis whatever it is so
you know an honest broker
who
was easily frightened
might find themselves in the wrong camp
somebody who was easily persuaded by
financial incentives or other
kinds of opportunities might find
themselves in the wrong place we have no
way of knowing you know what is a gorski
i don't know
um it could be any one of a number of
things right he could be
uh you know in it for
in it for the lulls i doubt it he's too
dedicated you know he could have
financial conflicts of interest i don't
know but
um
but
all i can say is
the evidence is out of phase with many
people's behavior whom who you would
expect to have
stepped up and i think in some sense
what has happened to people who have
who have evaluated the evidence and
spoken openly about it is the causal
factor
right why does a guy like jimmy wales
allow this to take place
on wikipedia you would imagine that he
would this this is his baby he would
defend the objectivity of wikipedia
to the fullest extent possible why would
he not well it may be
that he like everybody else is concerned
about
his
reputation and his legacy and all of
that and that this
seems like
not a hill he wants to die
yeah no i think you're probably right
there yeah
in terms of the motivation of these
people i i actually don't think you look
at someone like alex brown i mean um i
don't i don't think he's in it i don't
think there's isn't it for the money
these are these aren't he's an island
you know he goes back you look at stuff
over the years he he he thinks he knows
he thinks he thinks he's saving these
people think they're saving the world
some of them do they think they're
saving the world from people like us
well
the problem is there's another
explanation so
my field is is
biology but i take a complex systems
approach and so there are a lot of ways
you can end up with a particular
behavior and one of them that i worry
about
is what i call freelancing
so if there is an incredibly let's just
take a cartoon version i'm not saying
that this is what's going on but let's
imagine for a second that what was
driving the garbage public health
narrative was really
pharma profits pure and simple okay
repurposed drugs don't make profits
these transfection agents that we call
vaccines are very profitable mandates
make them even more so
um so let's imagine that's what was
driving the nonsense
well
very powerful forces have
literally
hundreds of billions of dollars at stake
in that question right if the repurposed
drugs work and the transfection agents
are dangerous and or ineffective
hundreds of billions of dollars will not
end up in certain pockets that's very
powerful so then the question is well
what if i'm
nobody in particular
and i detect that there are hundreds of
billions of dollars out there hoping
that the world will become persuaded of
certain things
and so all i do is i just start
innovating i see how i make nonsense
arguments what i've been pointing out is
sophistry i engage in sophistry in which
i defend the safety of the transfection
agents right i defend their efficacy i
come up with clever arguments against
this that or the other study that seems
to cast doubt on them and i put it into
the world and i see what happens right
and the point is
maybe some wealth finds its way to me
maybe suddenly i find myself being
followed by large numbers of people
right yeah
in other words um
if you imagine
freelancers trying to figure out whose
boots are worth licking right now you're
absolutely right those people get get
big followings yeah yeah
they they end up rising in the world and
so in a world like that i don't know
what to do my you know i've seen
analyses of david gorsky that raise
questions about conflicts of interest
i'm very curious about them of course
um
what to do about alex brown i've never
heard of the man until i read your
article um but you weren't aware that
he'd been responsible for yourself all
your stuff right i mean you know
as you say i don't check my wikipedia
page right and then somebody alerts you
and you go and you're looking oh my god
wow that's terrible and um
yeah so i do think we have to worry
about what i'm calling freelancers which
are people who may not have official
conflicts of interest but who have
discovered that if they say things that
are very pleasing to powerful forces
that are eager to shape the narrative
that good things happen to them yeah
yeah i mean that's that's that's a very
that's that's a very good point yeah i
mean
yeah and there's that but that's it but
it but
on this whole coding there's there is a
it's like it's a relatively small clique
you know on wikipedia on on
twitter and whatever who are always in
there i mean i you know and there are
everybody i mean everybody
you know would have been a
uh would have been attacked you know by
gorsky by people like health nerd
uh sky goals mcalpine
um
a guy called kyle sheldrick
i don't know you probably you know i
mean and some of the some of the some
stuff's been appalling and they've even
they tried they'd really try and destroy
people i mean do you know what happened
for example um
with the paul marrick um
absolutely with uh kyle sheldrick who uh
exactly i was involved you know i i i
mean that was that was it that was
incredible you know suddenly because
they don't like what what he's saying on
you know things like either met him they
suddenly start digging out old you know
old papers like that and coming up with
these ridiculous accusations of fraud i
mean yeah i mean
here you have here you have a
incredibly uh
decent doctor
highly decorated
uh who's
you know who goes to work and saves
lives that's what he does and he's being
slandered for
outright fraud that obviously did not
take place that is in the mind of uh
kyle sheldrick who misunderstood what he
was reading and you know hyperventilated
about it
doesn't understand that he thinks he's a
statistician doesn't understand sort of
basic statistics and yeah
i mean and that's the problem is in this
freelancer category i'm talking about
that's a feature not a bug
right you've got a lot less to do if you
understand statistics well um yeah but
if you don't then you have all sorts of
room to engage in sophistry and um and
you know to to destroy people's lives
and reputations you know you have to be
unscrupulous too which is apparently a
common feature of people but
um
but in any case okay so
what is the what happened next in your
in your story with you know so the
interesting thing is i i seem to have
been
successful where you guys well maybe you
haven't tried i don't know but
because i put out
this um detailed description of what
happened and a description of why
the statement that you know been
attributed to me and
uh had been a misinterpretation of a
misinterpreted
article
um and it was clear that that was the
case it was you know there's no dispute
because you can go and look at the heart
document you can see that it even went
to even said that the the um
uh
any
it had some disclaimer even the the the
the any um
uh statements whatever expressions in
the papers is not representative of
heart you know as an organization so
all of that was clear
um and i think the pressure may be that
they really just really in the end you
must have given up because they they
they took the whole covered 19
misinformation segment out of my
wikipedia page right as i looked at it
just a few days ago it gone
amazingly well um you know i think
you're right i haven't tried to do
anything about it in part i just haven't
been certain what to do as you say i'm
not deeply familiar with
how wikipedia is
i don't know anything about the internal
politics or the mechanisms
obviously section 230 uh creates a major
obstacle
to using the courts as they would
obviously be rightly used in this case
um
you know it's effectively a loophole
that has to be fixed in our legal
structure because uh you know alex brown
can libel using the megaphone of
wikipedia and his ability to shut down
anybody else's uh protest of his
misinformation
so i haven't known what to do my hope is
that actually
jimmy wales will
look at this podcast
and he will think very carefully about
the fact that he has
here jimmy let me talk to you directly
actually if you're watching this
i want to tell you something
about my grandfather
um
my grandfather
was
uh
he was a wonderful guy his name was
harry rubin and he
held a lifelong conviction that if
people could manage to see past their
mundane day-to-day interests that we
would be capable of
great things and that although the
market
created wonderful things it was not the
only mechanism for the production of of
tremendous value
and shortly before he died
i showed him wikipedia
right i opened up my laptop and i said i
want to show you something harry
take a look at this you were right
this is the greatest encyclopedia in the
history of the world by orders of
magnitude and it was not generated by
the profit motive this was
crowdsourced it ain't perfect but wow is
it better than the next nearest
competitor by an incredible degree so i
showed him that i was very
pleased to to let him know before he
died that um that that instinct of his
was borne out by something as marvelous
as wikipedia for wikipedia now to be
guilty of outright libeling people who
dared simply to talk to the public about
what was in their own interests in the
instance of a frightening emerging
pandemic is appalling
there is no way that you should be
allowing wikipedia to be used in that
way even if we were wrong just simply
report the facts accurately
libeling us is unacceptable and the fact
that it may be protected by section 230
is irrelevant right this is the library
of alexandria and if it can't be fixed
then it has to be replaced because at
the moment what it's doing is it's
sitting in the niche of the great global
democratizing encyclopedia and it is
preventing us from putting together
something else that will do the job if
wikipedia refuses to so
look it's line in the sand time either
fix the damn thing so it is not possible
to destroy somebody if you're uh you
know a freelance
uh editor who decides they have a
perspective that they want to turn into
a fact right either fix the damn thing
or get the hell out of the way because
we need something that does the job of
wikipedia and the fact that
founders like larry sanger believe that
it can't be fixed well that's a
challenge to you it is time it is time
to fix this mechanism and uh you know
maybe wikipedia 2.0 is the answer
well i said yeah all right
um so what else should we uh talk about
in the uh actually there's a funny thing
i i picked up
with regard to the original times
article there's something quite amusing
i thought i'd share with you
um uh let me just bring this up so the
original times article
um the online not the online version but
the print version of course they can't
change that right that was particularly
ridiculous because it had the heading of
it was academics back bizarre claim that
jabs may kill tonight i mean that in
itself with hindsight is quite an
amusing statement but do you want to
know something even funnier
it's a double page spread
that this was that this article was in
massive spread on on it it came out on
the i'm looking at tuesday march the
23rd
and um
the head the top headline right across
this right across the top you know what
it says
it says oxford vaccine that's the
astrazeneca 100 effective against severe
covid in us trial
right
that's the headline right which we now
you know how wrong could that be but
here's an interesting thing you may not
your american viewers might not be aware
about this whole thing i mean how much
do you know about the the history of
what happened to the astrazeneca vaccine
in in
you know throughout the world wow
i look forward to hearing
right so the astrazeneca vaccine um of
course was produced oxford and they
claim oh it's not for pr unlike pfizer
and madonna it's not for profit this is
you know this is gonna this is the uk
you know uk's brilliant research
scientists
saving the world you know um
uh without any sort of profit modes
that's the way it was it was sold and
you know that the woman uh was it sarah
gilbert who was one of the uh prominent
scientists involved she got a dame hood
very soon afterwards and a sort of
standing ovation at wimbledon center
court in june of that year right so
that's the sort of context of it and
when the vaccines first came out
almost everybody in the uk was getting
astrazeneca right because it was you
know it was it was british b because it
was actually even i'd you know the stuff
i'd heard about the sort of the you know
what the
so
because of the slightly different style
of accident was you know even i thought
well maybe it's not gonna it's not
potentially as dangerous as the as the
you know the pfizer uh technology right
so there was that aspect of it and and
so
you know you know that's what people
everyone was getting there okay um and
you know
so this is this was this was going on
until um
june
until about july of that year then
suddenly of course there'd been stories
stories were already coming out about
severe adverse reactions with blood
clots and there was actual reports of
of deaths right and you know there was a
bbc
uh presenter you know you know but you
know on the coroner actually recalled it
as as um
a astrazeneca
vaccine induced death so these stories
um were coming around and they were also
stopped we you were hearing things like
in other european countries there was no
longer they certainly would stop
stopping to give it giving it to anybody
under the age of 30 and stuff like that
well the interesting thing is in the uk
there was never an out there there was
never and has never been any public
announcement about what happened to
astrazeneca right but as early as i
think it started i think that i i went
to my gp right and asked the question
about astrazeneca i think it was in uh
it was either might be august 2021 uh
2020 this is you know right you know
august 2020 what's happened you know
what what's happening with us
said oh no we're not giving that any we
we haven't got that anymore
what do you mean you haven't got it
anymore we're not we're not being given
it we're not we're not we there's
nothing there are no supplies of it
anymore is it because supplies have run
out or whatever to cut a long story
short
the reason why they've not made
any formal announcement is because to
all intents and purposes it has been
completely withdrawn but they won't say
don't they the reason they won't say it
because what they the way around it is
that they claim that you can still ask
for it you can go to your gp surgery or
you can go to one of the clinics and say
that you want to have the astrozenica
vaccine and it will be supplied to you
but the fact that most gp surgeries
don't have it anymore and you know very
few doses are being given
you know gets them out of the fact that
they they don't have to admit that this
has been a catastrophic disaster it was
a catastrophic disaster and you know you
know that whole fanfare about you know
this was this was britain saving the
world you know doesn't that they they
stop it stops the embarrassment about it
and and you know that most of many
countries in europe it absolutely is you
know that you
the fact that they really have banned it
right so britain officially hasn't
banned it but to all intents and
purposes that's just to say if that's
just a safe face it has shadow banned it
yeah
effectively yeah yeah which is
fascinating i mean and the number of
games that are obviously being played uh
i don't know what to make frankly of the
uh the astrazeneca
fiasco i don't know what to make of the
interaction between the mrna vaccines
here in the u.s and the the adenovector
dna based vaccines
i certainly
um
have
been struck by the number of independent
failures and errors in
the
the basic
model by which the rna
vaccinations function right the fact
that they were heavily stabilized with
pseudo-uridines they had no uh
targeting mechanism so at the point that
we discovered that they were circulating
in the body that ought to have set off
alarm bells but in any case
i don't know what to make i don't know
how much of the battle
over which vaccine
is really a corporate battle taking
place as if it was a scientific battle
that's an interesting very interesting
point because when i've raised this
thing about the astrovenica people the
defenders say ah now estrovenica's still
you know should be should have been much
more widely available it's just because
you know as they got muscled out by
fizer you know that fires a you know the
fires on madonna muscle them out so
that's that's the kind of that's the
other argument to sort of you know say
that's that's a saving grace argument
which is which the no doubt government
ministers will probably if you actually
got them to speak about it and never do
but if they if you did they would
probably give you some messaging like
that but can i ask you i can ask you a
question here it's quite interesting one
of the other reasons why they were in
the uk they were saying astrazeneca
science better than fires it was this
thing that pfizer had to be stored at
some bizarrely low temperature behind 70
degrees and that was a major problem for
you know you were the way the uk
vaccines were kind of like distributed
and and given in the uk
well apparently whatever happened to
that that requirement because as far as
i know that that's suddenly no longer
yeah they no longer they no longer have
that requirement it's always just stored
anywhere i remember
but only vaguely some sort of revision
in that claim very early in the
distribution of these things
again i don't know what to make of any
of this what i know
is that
pfizer seems to have won out
um
and that's the exact inverse of what
should have happened when the competitor
was johnson johnson
a vaccine that i still have concerns
about but
on multiple different levels from the
fact that it's one shot rather than two
that because it's dna and not rna the
pseudo-uridine fiasco has not affected
it
and the you know this one's hard to
explain
but
the problem
with the mrna vaccines
one of them
is that the lipid nanoparticles that are
used to get this into cells
are this is effectively a
pseudovirus
right the lipid nanoparticles are taking
the place of the nucleocapsid
but because they are not the product of
evolution
they are completely haphazard with
respect to what cells they
uh enter that's not true for
a virus like an adenovirus
an adenovirus has an ecology of its own
it has a logic and so it doesn't really
have any reason as far as i know to
invade your heart cells because it can't
spread from there and so
the the idea of using
a virus as a vector
while it sounds scary is far safer as
far as i would guess
than using a completely uh arbitrary
mechanism like lipid nanoparticles
and so
in any case
the fact that uh
dr ben and her group has found an
all-cause mortality slight all-cause
mortality benefit with the
dna based and an all-cause mortality
harm from the rna-based vaccines fits
what heather and i predicted we said
look none of this
the thing that set us off the thing that
caused us to uh
join the skeptic community here
was that we were told that these
vaccines were safe and effective
there's
you know
safe means you know that they don't do
harm and there's no way they could have
known that it didn't do harm two years
out five years out because they hadn't
existed long enough so we knew that that
had to be a lie we didn't know what sort
of lie it was
but
what we said was none of this is safe
because it's all too new we don't know
what the effect is but
in terms of the relative safety the
adenovectored
vaccines are likely to be a lot safer
and if we had to take one that's what we
would do
that's what we said and it turns out
that that is now uh
borne out by
uh the data at least with the j j
and i do wonder about the astrazeneca
i mean the thing is though that all of
the i mean all of the evidence now
is pointing to
um
certainly no evidence we
even if we avoid saying how harmful they
might be as you said there's certainly
no evidence that they're safe right and
there's and for pfizer there's
definitely no evidence that they that
they lead to a decrease in all cause and
mortality right but the fact that
it that's now even
that there's no dispute i mean people
might dispute those there's no dispute
about the fact that it doesn't stop
infection transmission and the fact that
all the evidence points to
increased
transmission amongst people that are
vaccinated why is it still going on why
why are there demands to you know for
continual boosters what's
you know if it's not i mean is it is it
now are we at the stage where the the
push for that is not so much the profit
i mean there is obviously there's going
to be the profit factor in there but do
you think there's also beside this
notion
that they want to kind of like eliminate
the control group for fear of what might
happen with the safety profile i worry
very much about this they're they're
fervor to vaccinate
uh to transfect i should i should be
disciplined about that they're fervor to
transfect people for whom there is
clearly no rational argument young
healthy people did not need these things
no matter what
and
the
desire
to inoculate them is bizarre and one
possible explanation is this issue of
the control group i would also point out
i don't know what happened with
astrazeneca maybe the astrazeneca shot
is as dangerous as you were led to
believe
on the other hand
if
the astrazeneca shot
has the same relationship
to
the pfizer and modernist shots that uh
dr ben found
with um
uh with all-cause mortality and the
relationship between
the j and j and the
pfizer moderna
then
obviously there's a compare there's a
statistical comparison to be done
between people who got the one version
and the other and if for example
the stabilization of the mrnas using
pseudo-uridines in every uracil location
if that turned out to be a massive error
that caused a tremendous amount of harm
that comparison would show it to you
so
who knows i wish we
we need institutions that are capable of
asking these questions we need skeptics
who are empowered and we just don't have
it the trouble is i mean again i can
tell you um some of the manipulations
the mechanisms in the uk which are sort
of prolonging let's say
a justifying the continuation a lot of
it comes from
um we've done a lot of work on these
statistics which are
on vaccine surveillance statistics from
the office for national statistics and
there's a massive controversy about this
but out and we've raised these concerns
and they've not really been
they've not accepted so i don't know if
you're aware that i can just give you a
very a brief synopsis about what the
problem is so the problem
is that all of their data
right first of all it's based on a
somewhat biased sample it's based on all
people
who were in the 2011 census in the uk
in 2011 and who were registered with a
gp in
2019 right so it's a subset of the
population they're making all these
estimates about the proportion of
unvaccinated uh in the population based
on that it's quite you know it's quite
um
it's not you know it's not an exhaust
it's nothing like an exhaustive subset
for a start right so that's their data
right but they're getting information so
obviously they've got data on deaths and
they're supposed to have accurate data
on vaccination status of
everybody body there but of course what
we know is happening
um i'm sure there's something that you
you know you'll be aware of as well is
that
the whether or not someone is classified
as vaccinated or not
right or one those two those three does
whatever
is is susceptible to let's say
significant manipulation some of it
deliberate some but not so in the case
of we know that for any of effectiveness
effectiveness studies they'll classify
they'll say well you can't consider the
vaccine to be effective until you've had
it for two weeks so anybody who gets
covered in that time we we don't count
them as as as a covered case you've got
this unbelievable built-in bias where
you're guaranteed even with a even with
a known um placebo you're given you'd
get a statistical artifact which shows
very high
efficacy
and then waiting i understood that now
it's a pure statistical art it's a pure
statistical artifact you get that um
similarly if you get delayed reporting
you get the same thing but the same
thing happens with deaths and this is
really bad so they will say
they'll claim no we we
if someone
has had the vaccine and dies 24 hours
later no we classify that as a
vaccinated death no we know that doesn't
happen we know that most of the people
who die shortly after the first dose are
classified as unvaccinated we know that
most of people who die shortly after
um the second dose classified as one
though so you get this again this
misclassification and that
misclassification is skewing all of
their data right
to the extent that we actually and also
we know
right so that that skews any results
they claim about safety and effect
efficacy because they claim well no the
data's showing that that it is both you
know safe safe and effective but we also
showed
um
that hey it couldn't be true because
actually what happens is that when you
look at their own data you do a plot
of the what happens with all calls that
non-covered deaths
shortly after the roll out of
vaccination you get this bizarre thing
whereby the unvaccinated get a peak in
non-coveted deaths when the vaccination
program is rolled out so somehow
when you're vaccinating a whole load of
people all those who aren't getting
vaccinated are suddenly dying of
non-covered diseases
well that's that
that proves that there's a
misclassification and you know they came
with this ridiculous idea we challenged
them we spoke at them about it said oh
well that's the that's the healthy
vaccine effect we proved that couldn't
be the case by looking at looking at
historical data so we but they're still
maintaining it but now the big thing is
they've got this all the data was based
on a bizarre
literally a bizarre underestimate
of the proportion of people who actually
aren't vaccinated in the uk so they
claim
that only
four million
which is eight percent of uk adults are
unvaccinated
now if you if you underestimate that
proportion and that's the denominator in
all of your effectiveness and safety
things and obviously you're going to
massively exaggerate the effectiveness
and safety of the vaccine which is what
they're doing
well we've we've challenged them on this
there are other other government
agencies
so the same uk government another agency
called the united kingdom health
security agency is saying that over 20
of adults are unvaccinated there's a big
difference from twenty percent and eight
percent if you're using that as a
denominator everything switches with
that with the uk hsa denominator you get
in every single age group you get an
increase a significant increase in
all-cause mortality so let me understand
vaccinated if there are more
unvaccinated then
are being allowed for certain
calculations
then the fact that they are not
experiencing an increase in negative
health effects that are downstream of
the effectively the vaccines are
borrowing some of the health of
unvaccinated people exactly to increase
the appearance that they are safe that's
exactly it simple as that yeah
and
um
there's another i've been i've been like
on loads i've done loads of podcasts
last two weeks because there was a bbc
two documentary called unvaccinated
which fun enough was hosted by hannah
fry was my co-presenter when i you know
did my bbc documentary but she's gone on
since then you know to be very famous
she's like now like the lead she's like
the face of science in the uk
so she did this program called
unvaccinated which is the most biased
unbelievably biased program they got
seven unvaccinated people and tried to
basically convince them over a week to
get vaccinated they weren't supposed to
be they tried it was supposed to be
objective you know they were supposed to
say to say give them you know arguments
you know both ways and find out why they
weren't vaccinated but it was the most
biased thing they brought in the experts
and felt they failed to declare
these people like fires are that strong
associated with fires these are the
experts so all that anyway but the
interest you know it was really
interesting i picked up on this point
about it is at the start of the program
they so the reason i pricked my ears up
that's first started blogging about is
because they were making this claim
about only only about only eight percent
unvaccinated and they were trying to
claim this is some tiny fringe crazy
minority and i knew that figure was
wrong i knew that was based on this
wrong ons data so i started to raise a
concern straight away
but the program and they actually
obviously to be fair they changed the
headline on one of their articles which
was you know advertising the program
they took that they took that
eight that four million or eight percent
off the headline but it was still a key
feature of programs the program started
with hannah fryer saying
despite you know this great vaccine
vaccination program you know there's
still four million uk adults who are
unvaccinated right eight percent making
out making out that was far too big a
number right
right but you know what she said this is
incredible and i then checked out and i
looked at the source for this she said
that in preparation for the program the
bbc had done their own
large survey representative uh survey
of over 2 500 uk adults
and they found
that
600 well it was actually which was 24
and actually we looked at the source
data from study it really was a very
good
survey it was actually 26
unvaccinated and that's a big sample
that's a big sample in fact you know
using sort of standard statistical
arguments that means the probability
that the true number is less than 20
percent unvaccinated is effectively zero
so there really are you know there
really are over 20 percent unvaccinated
contrary to what you know is the basis
for all of these safety and efficacy
claims
you know the whole
cove
evidentiary picture
is just it's like a hall of mirrors
right you are looking at something and
you have no idea whether it's an actual
something
or a created something or a
misinterpretation of something but
the let's put it this way
i hope it is a complex problem
it's not this complex right we have
hundreds of years frankly of work
figuring out how you analyze things
we've gotten good at analyzing for
simple patterns like
you know if you had this treatment are
you more or less likely to die over x
period of time that's not a difficult
problem
so the fact that
we can't get anything right
we can't say things definitively because
the entire thing has been reduced to
some kind of
bizarre team sport
it's unreal right it's not this hard
get some smart people put them in a room
immunize them from bad consequences and
have them talk about how you would
figure out where we are and what to do
about it
if it's not going to happen is it it's
too late it's too late yeah no no they
they've um
they've committed themselves
because if we were to do that it would
reveal
the level of
at the very least uh indifference to
human death and suffering but what do
you think about you know people like
deborah bucks coming out now and saying
they knew all along that you know they
were basically lying about the the
effectiveness of the vaccine i mean it
doesn't isn't doesn't that isn't that
going to wake people up it doesn't seem
to have done actually well i have to
tell you i i see these things and i
often have less of a reaction
to them
than other people do because at some
level
i mean i think it's just been obvious
that there is at least a group of people
who have risen to
to the heights of power
who are
uh
very very comfortable with lying
look comfortable at a level that
you have rarely met anyone who could do
it uh you know i mean
fouchya i think is top of this list
that's the sure ease with which he tells
what he must know our fictions is
incredible and so if you imagine that
that's one of the skills that puts you
uh in a position of power uh under our
system then this becomes less surprising
and you know i mean i guess your
question is a good one will it wake
other people up
yeah i hope so um and i i actually think
that
we in the skeptic community
um
have
misplayed our hand a little bit
because the biological reality
is
you may have
been misled by these people
you may have done things that have
compromised your health but this is
cumulative the sooner you stop listening
to the people who are giving you bad
advice
the better off you will be
and
i'm not telling you who those people are
but i am telling you that we have a
mechanism for knowing who they are and
that mechanism is science which which
means
that
predictive power is the guide right
people who have done a good job of
predicting what was going to happen
those are people worth listening to
could they be lucky
uh every so often but you can't be
continually lucky right you can't you
can't predict a complex system with a
high degree of accuracy if you don't
have a good model for what's taking
place and if people have predicted
abysmally
stop listening to them they're just
they're either they're corrupt or
they're
you know there's a problem you know
there's a problem here again from the
scientific um credibility angle i'll
tell you what it is it's that it's this
whole notion of um peer-reviewed you
know published peer-reviewed papers
right because then they'll say they'll
take what you said right okay well let's
go to let's go to the establishment what
is the established science sciences what
right you know what are the credit what
are the generally credible sources will
people think well it's the people it's
got to be these peer-reviewed papers
well you know this whole thing has been
corrupted but again most people don't
interested in incidentally this is
another interesting about wikipedia here
they will argue that they will only sign
it and of course it's all nonsense
because they do it they they again do it
as they feel fit they'll change this but
they'll they'll claim that again
that they'll reject anything that sort
of one of the skeptics says if it's not
published and you know that you can't
have that that's not an appearance
that's not in a good enough or that's
not in a peer-reviewed journal right
well
it's got to the stage now where um you
know that i mean
forget about the well-known instance
like with you know i mean my colleague
i'm close calling jessica rose and she
had this paper with piece of macallah
that was published but then completely
mysteriously withdrawn and there's a few
other
um examples like that coming out now and
that
sort of made the news where they're
basically trying to get perfectly
respectable
um papers which seriously challenge you
know the safe and effective narrative
they they're getting them they're
getting the withdrawn so they won't
appear in uh peer review publications
but be beneath that you've got to think
of the massive stuff you know stuff that
we've done colleagues of mine which
doesn't even get to the stage of being
peer reviewed now if my name now is on a
paper
it will not get it be immediately
returned and they won't say because of
my name they'll immediately say it's a
not sufficient interest the journal or
but you know it goes well it's worse
than this because you know that there
are the um the rp
um
the you've got these um
pre-print uh servers like med archive
and archive they won't they won't you
know they won't allow my papers either
yep well so there's my name there so i'm
on a list because they they unlike the
one place i put them is research because
there's absolutely no
screening process there anyone which is
curious that's actually that's actually
funded by bill melinda gates foundation
that's a separate thing but so far we've
been able to put stuff on research gate
right without any problems and it
certainly gets massive number of reads
of papers there but if i now go to med
archive or archive they have a screening
process whether which they claim
is to they there's obviously some
automated process or whatever which
looks at whether it's in scope or
whatever whether it's whether there's
plagiarism i can understand that because
they can check whether it's a plate you
know where it's a plagiarized so i can
understand that
right but mine are always what happens
after three days they'll come back and
say
something like out of scope this is a
normal one or and that's ridiculous
because no nothing is out it it's
clearly in scope and nothing should get
rejected there so my name
is on is in the screening hours
triggering right and then the
the problem is this cr so
first of all any place that you could
lodge a correct analysis of the evidence
is a threat to whatever it is that is
driving this whatever it is
and therefore
uh if it's the peer-reviewed journals
they will be captured
if it is the pre-print servers then they
will be
manipulated right if it is
uh
podcasts then they will be demonetized
and uh struck from youtube so the basic
point is look you're searching for a
venue and the thing knows that the one
thing you can't be allowed to have is a
venue right
um heather and i have uh said many times
on our podcast
that peer review is not the same thing
as review by peers that the public has
been lured into a belief that peer
review is some sort of mechanism
important to science it is no such thing
any scientist worth their salt wants
their work reviewed by peers but the
system of peer peer review this secret
non-transparent
system is a mechanism of control and it
is not serving science it is serving
power
so
um
the hard part for people to stomach is
that if something is powerful enough i
mean look we know
that pharma manipulates journals that it
manipulates departments that it
manipulates fields we know that it does
that it's well studied
the idea that it
do we think it stopped doing that during
covid do we think it's doing it at a
normal level do we think it stepped it
up we never have that conversation we
simply pretend that it's on the same
team trying to cure covet as the rest of
us yeah and at the point you recognize
that
the
major
medical associations that
most doctors that most
all universities as far as i know
that the major journals that all of
these things have landed on a team
that team has a narrative
you as a member of the public can know
that that team is spouting nonsense i
mean
let's put it this way
um if effective
means you need four doses in less than
two years and it still doesn't control
contraction or transmission of the
disease if that's what effective means
what a safe mean
right
right effective obviously doesn't mean
effective i'm thinking safe might not
mean safe either so at the point you
realize somebody's telling me oh yeah
this is safe you should get it and that
person will
you know they didn't do very well with
effective and i can tell that myself
because i'm being told i need my fourth
dose right at that point
i'm not saying this is a good thing but
i am saying at that point you should
stop listening to the people who told
you it was effective because they were
wrong they have not acknowledged that
they were wrong they haven't explained
how that happened or what you should
think now
right you should not listen to them and
you should say well
it would be great if there were an
institution or a publication i could go
to
that would tell me the truth
doesn't exist so
maybe i should start looking around for
people who have left a record of what
they've thought over the course of the
pandemic and i should start looking for
people for whom that record suggests
that they do understand what's going on
right that's very difficult to find is
you know you go on a google search and
you're not going to be you search for
you know your name you'll get to just
you know you'll get the decision you'll
find out that i'm a notorious spreader
of miss dis and male information
um
i mean the whole the way i mean this is
another thing we haven't touched on but
i mean and you've of course your own
experience uh you know
bears this out even before covert is
that is the
is that is how academia which you know
was traditionally supposed to be you
know all about free speech you know
progressive standing up for i mean you
know you know standing up for the
disadvantaged and and confronting the
you know big tech and big i mean how
they suddenly how have they
i mean it was happening before covert
but with covid especially how they
suddenly been completely almost done
night i would say 99
captured even
they've just totally
been in this sort of you know this this
this
you know
this this narrative of we have to have
control we have to we have to censor
anybody who disagrees with them we've
got to ostracize those people we've got
to humiliate them i mean where is the
traditional academic you know
progressive liberal ideals you know it's
completely banished
and
and
in parallel where is the hippocratic
oath
exactly for the clinicians yep that that
seems to have gone out the window yeah
right so so you know i used to say back
before covid
when people would ask me about academia
and what we could do to save it and my
feeling is well a
some of us have been shouting about this
for decades this is not a new problem
and the fact that it is now so
uh clear that everybody can see it
doesn't mean you know this is now the
point of you know you've had covid for
a week and you want to know what to do
about it and the answer is well you
should have started treating it on day
one same thing for academia now
we have to switch analogies here a
little bit but the basic point is look
academia is like
your family dog after it's contracted
rabies
right the right way to think about it is
not that's the family dog the right way
to think about it is oh my god that
animal has rabies
right and
you're gonna need you're gonna need a
new dog and that other dog has to go
and
um i don't know you know i would not
have let the situation get there but
we're there and it doesn't make any
sense to pretend otherwise but it's
clearly
totally captured and yeah i mean look
what happened to you at evergreens i
mean that was you know that's nothing to
probably that's happened that that's you
know that that kind of thing is
you know is is happening to a lot of
people i mean you know that i
i've never ever had a complaint about my
teaching anywhere until this whole thing
started and this you know
before i even you know before i even
gave my you know
i do this masters module but to a big
class at 260 students or so
a group of students you know
went to the head of school and said you
know we're not going to be we refuse to
be taught by this misinformation
anti-vaxx anti-vaccine guide even though
it's a compulsory module we demand to be
moved to another another module i mean
i've never you could never believe this
happen and and the fact that i don't get
supported by you know the
the
students are the ones who who you know
apparently are in the right to be
concerned about this you know the lack
of support the lack of support i mean
not just that but
the lack of support for you know what
you know the kind of nonsense i've had
to put up with throughout this has been
it's it's just it's remarkable how this
you just realize that there's nobody in
equity you've got a few
close colleagues you trust right but
beyond that you you absolutely know that
you're not going to get any support you
know from anyone you get well it's
interesting
especially with this subject because
although you know a lot of the stuff
that we do
is you know it does have the sort of
complex bayesian stuff but actually
most of the data analysts the most stuff
we've been revealing anyone with you
know with a sort of basic understanding
of statistics you know you know score
you know you know not even high school
level but just basic statistics will
know could point out the problems yeah
and yet where are the step where are the
where are the top statisticians and
other mathematicians standing up right
absolutely absolutely silent or actually
criticizing us right which which has to
be based in fear
right yes because i've had you know that
i have had i have had a small number of
very very senior very very um you know
top rated statisticians contact me
privately and say
they understand and they support it but
they can't speak out to be the end of
their careers i mean i can only really
do it because i'm i'm you know i'm a
retirement age it would be different it
would have been difficult for me so i
would probably have been just as much a
coward as that as then you know if this
was you know if this was 15 years ago i
don't know
well this is this is why i i don't hold
back with the analogies like
rabies
right the point is look
yeah i'm not it's not a good thing that
your dog has rabies but you know
rationalizing about it is going to make
things much worse yeah right so yeah i i
don't know
i'm shocked i'm as shocked as i am at
academics
i'm even more shocked by the doctors
yeah yeah right
this is basic nuremberg uh hippocratic
oath stuff
and the thing is but lots of them it's
it's like they've not taken it's not
that they know that they're doing wrong
they don't it's just that they they are
simply
getting the mainstream information
they're not attempting to find out
themselves okay but i've challenged
doctors on this who are you know you
know you yeah you're getting a science
guy okay here's my contention you're
right the doctors do not know they are
doing harm but
that is on
the user's side in other words the
amount of work the doctors have to do to
avoid the information that they're doing
harm is substantial
so
i i really think
whatever it is that we are up against
whatever is spreading the real
uh misinformation and advancing this
incredibly wrong-headed narrative
that thing smartest thing it ever did
was
force the hand of the doctors early
right because the point is
to
to revert to recognize what is taking
place also means to acknowledge the harm
you've participated in already and i
think that's a very
uh
high bar and i i i'm still shocked that
doctors aren't crossing it in large
numbers
but um but nonetheless it does
i think it is easier to double down on
yeah yeah no you're absolutely i think
you're right yeah you're right on that
no doubt about it yeah
yeah it's it's it's really it's really
tragic but nonetheless here we are
it's 2022
our institutions have i mean look they
were captured now the degree to which
they were captured is revealed to us if
we will simply look at it and everything
from uh medicine to academia to
wikipedia all of these things are
mainstream media goals mainstream media
maybe went first but yeah yeah it's
capturing it
well academia the rot began probably in
academia certainly in the 90s we saw
hints of it i think i think it was stuff
before then
oh well that may be i certainly saw it
in the 90s in college yeah
but in any case yes all of the
institutions are infected by this
particular
pathology and
the danger to us couldn't be greater so
as unpleasant as it is to look that
reality in the eye it's far safer than
ignoring it for another who knows how
long yeah this isn't going to get better
until we look at it
unfortunately you're correct in that i
fear
yeah
all right well um this has been a
marvelous discussion i want to thank you
for
your courage and for in particular i
want to personally thank you for
exploring the question of what was going
on at wikipedia even if nobody
uh does anything it was um
you know
looking at your wikipedia page
libel you in such vicious terms
uh it is very much the experience of
being gas-lit
right
and
to know something to know the name of uh
parties involved behind the scenes to
know how it unfolds
um
is uh it's um heartening and i hope it
leads to positive change yeah i hope
your message so jimmy gets through yeah
i hope so too
all right well um
thank you for joining us where can
people find you who are interested in
easiest places norman fenton.com because
that's got the links to my twitter and
youtube and blog and that kind of thing
great and it also uh your youtube has
some wonderful explanations of bayesian
logic among other things with uh
graphics that are easy to follow so if
you're curious about
um how how bayesian thinking works and
what what role it played in this
conversation
i strongly encourage you to go look at
those they're they're quite excellent
all right um well thank you uh for
joining us and thank you thank you for
the opportunity to speak all right good
i hope we meet in person soon
yeah all right be well yep bye bye
you